- I was like you.
I decided it'd be cool to hang out
with some of the tough kids.
(grunting)
You know who I'm talking about?
They were hanging on the
streets late at night.
More than cigarette smokers, Homes.
And then
one day
I got shot out of a catapult.
- That's it.
(cell door closing and slamming)
- Now I know this plan is foolproof.
Check this out.
First of all, you and me
start working at the bank.
Doesn't matter the position, okay?
Just so long as we get in there, right?
Then we just go there every day,
do the work,
gain their trust until we get
them in the palm of our hand.
- All right?
So how we get the money?
- That's the beauty of it, bro.
They deposit the money
into our bank accounts.
Week after week, month after month.
They're not even going to
know they being robbed.
And then 20 or 30 years later,
we walk out the front door
like nothing even happened.
- Mother (beep) that's called a job.
(cell door slamming)
(alarm ringing)
(upbeat music)
- Here.
(tires screeching)
- Shit.
- What are you doing?
Come on.
- Wait, I'm coming.
(engine revving)
(tires screeching)
Stay where you are.
- What are you doing?
Stop, thank you.
(handle clunking)
(lock clicking)
- You're not locking it.
- We're doing it at the
same time is the problem.
- Unlock the door.
- No,
now.
(handle clunking)
Stop touching it while I do the lock.
- What do you want me to do?
- Just do it now.
(handle clunking)
Unbelievable.
- You're kidding me.
- Stop it and reset.
Put it down.
- I'm just holding it.
- Take your hand off.
- It is on the thing.
- I got to reset the thing.
Look, look at this, huh?
(lock clunking)
Huh, nothing happens if
you're holding it up.
Everybody knows not to do that.
'Cause now it's all jiggered
(growling)
in the middle.
You've got it all jiggered
in the middle now.
(groaning)
Stop.
- What?
- Take your hand
away from the door completely.
Thank you.
(lever shifting)
(tires screeching)
- Christ, you are going to get...
What happened?
What happened though, what happened?
I don't know what happened.
(cell door slamming)
(fist punching face)
(heavy breathing)
- Please.
No, no.
No.
(gun shooting)
(bullet shell hitting floor)
(laughing)
(laughing continues)
- What?
What's? What's the joke?
- I don't get it.
- Man, you shot that damn fool.
(laughing)
- Oh,
yeah.
No, I still don't get it.
- Hey, man, ain't nothing to get.
This is shit is just funny, man.
Dude can't snitch now.
(laughing)
(laughing building)
Man, don't fake laugh.
- Huh?
- That's not real.
I could tell.
- No, I think it's really funny.
- No you don't.
But look at him sitting there all dead.
(laughing)
- He was 20 and now he's dead.
He ain't ever going to
have a wife or kids now.
- Man, what are you doing?
Wife and kids?
That shit ain't funny.
(soft laughing)
- His mom and dad ain't
never going to see him again.
- No.
No.
You're ruining it for me.
- Okay, well, I guess I
just don't get it then.
- It's just that you shot him.
That's all.
That's the whole thing.
- Oh, okay, so.
(gun firing)
- Oh.
- The hell is wrong with you?
You don't shoot a dude
that's already dead.
That's not funny.
- Oh.
(gun firing)
(groaning)
- Ow.
(laughing)
(groaning)
- Yeah, I guess I just don't get it.
(cell door slamming)
(birds squawking)
(ominous music)
- [Narrator] Lewis Lawrence is
beginning his life sentence.
In order to survive, he must join a gang.
- But you understand, I
know how it work, right?
When you I prison, what you
need is protection right.
And the way to do that is
by getting into a gang.
I was surprised to find out
that there is a bald gang
in prison.
They're going to be my homies.
I'm talking about some BBWW,
Bald Brothers What What.
What's up, Homie.
Nice haircut.
- Get the (beep) out of here.
- I mean they haven't officially asked me
to be in the gang yet.
'Cause you need to earn
their respect first.
- Hey, you're in the wrong neighborhood.
Black mother (beep).
(ominous music)
(screaming)
- Step off my homies,
Mother (beep).
Or I will (beep) you up.
Bald brotherhood, y'all.
Yeah, bald brotherhood, what's up?
You know I'm talking you about.
(fist punching face)
(screaming)
(fist punching body)
(groaning)
That was it right there, okay.
That's what they call a jump in.
That's the initiation process.
So it's my understanding
that I am now a member
of the Bald Brotherhood Gang, okay.
(feet kicking body)
I mean, those mother (beep)
beat the (beep) out of me.
That's a euphemism you hear all the time.
But you don't know if it's true.
It can't be true.
How's it possible?
But that mother (beep) went bam.
And diarrhea just went (blowing air)
right out my ass.
So I hope, like,
I hope that's like
lifetime dudes right there.
What's up.
It's the happiest day of my
life, is what I'm saying.
- [Narrator] Despite the
lack of encouragement
Lewis continues to try and
ingratiate himself to the gang.
- [Lewis] What? This long haired, bitch?
(fist hitting body)
(grunting)
(foot kicking body)
Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about, Hero.
Trying to creep up on my bald brother's.
I ought to kick you again.
Wait, what?
(fist punching body)
(screaming)
(grunting)
(groaning)
(body hitting floor)
(feet kicking body)
(Lewis groaning and grunting)
- Hey, you all right man?
Come on, get up, get up.
We got you son, we got you son.
- Get your hands off me you
hair having mother (beep).
(fist punching body)
(grunting)
(body hitting ground)
(feet kicking body)
(grunting)
(screaming)
(inmates shouting)
(alarm wailing)
I mean, I think I accidentally got hit
by some of my bald brothers.
(inmates shouting)
(whistle blowing)
That's right, bald
brotherhood forever, man.
What's up.
(body hitting floor)
But you, that's prison, man.
I mean, you don't ever know
what side it's coming from.
- [Narrator] Lewis has
yet to make any alliances.
Meanwhile,
(laughing)
an unprecedented peace has been brokered
between black and white prison gangs.
The once insurmountable racial divide,
now bridged by a mutual hatred,
(prison door slamming)
for Lewis.
(ominous music fades)
(cell door slamming)
(school bell ringing)
(hand tapping on microphone)
- Okay, students, settle down.
Settle down.
That includes you, Mr. Rodriguez.
Do you want to take the milk
carton off of your head?
Thank you so much.
We have a special guest today.
He's from this neighborhood
and he's a former gang member.
And he's coming here this morning
to talk to you about life choices.
So please give a warm
Central High School welcome
to Donny Herrera.
(students applauding)
- I used to be just like you.
(soft music)
Just like you, you, you.
Used to clown around.
Make fun of the principle.
Put milk on my head just
like you, Rodriguez.
(students laughing)
And then
I got hit with aids.
Consequences.
Got into some real trouble.
Boy.
Stole from my mom and dad,
stole from my own sister.
And then one day
a piano fell on my head.
- What?
- Consequences.
(students chattering)
I feel like he missed a step there.
- Gave me 88 concussions.
One for each key.
You think I'm learning, but no.
See, I'm just like you.
I got back out there.
Started making some real crimes, home boy.
Oh yeah.
And then
I got trampled by a herd of buffalo.
- What?
(students chattering)
- Consequences.
- Okay, Donny.
I think we've heard enough.
- I'm not done with my story.
I was like you.
I decided it'd be cool
to hang out with some of the tough kids.
(grunting)
You know who I'm talking about.
They were hanging on the
streets late at night.
More than cigarette smokers, Homes.
And then
one day
I got shot out of a catapult.
- That's it, okay.
- Into the mouth of a dragon.
- Students, everything you've
heard here today is a lie.
- I don't lie anymore.
- You're all excused.
(students chattering)
(chairs and tables clanging)
- Look at me.
I shouldn't even be here.
- Thank you,
I apologize, Teresa.
- That's when I got
really deep in the crimes.
I did a drive by at my own
daughter's Quinceanera.
(sobbing)
(somber music)
Yeah.
Shot up everybody.
Dead, killed.
Yeah.
Then I got sucked into a wormhole.
Consequences.
- That's it.
Okay, everybody go.
(students chattering)
- I was in another dimension.
Tried to introduce my own
parents to each other.
Almost failed.
Arm was disappearing.
I invented "Johnny B.
Goode" at my parents prom.
And at the last moment they
kissed and it came back.
- [Principle] The faster we
get away from him, the better.
- But nobody believed me.
Where's my crack.
Oh, God.
(lighter clicking)
(glass smashing)
(rubble falling)
(screaming)
(wrecking ball hitting body)
Consequences.
(body hitting floor)
(upbeat outro music)
♪ Oh I want you ♪
♪ But I don't need you ♪